my name is James Callen Brassica and I
am the director of the speck pilot a
rock and a hard place last time we spoke
to you James you were on a busy stretch
and you said you may take some time off
but it seems like things are not slowing
down for you in fact it's the opposite I
really want to take some time off I just
have this horrible habit of like you
know I make like I make these projects
you know with like what has become my
family like you know it's you know the
crew the DP John de Fazio I work with
him on everything this will be our sixth
project together shannen doherty
who's acting in this this will be our
seventh project together and so it's you
know it's it's kind of like hey do you
want to get back together with a bunch
of your friends and create something fun
and it's like so one thing I really love
and feel at home doing so I think as
much as I decide that I want to take
some time off I feel like I've been
saying that for like four years I know
after this one I'm gonna take some time
off and it's either a that I actually do
want to take some time off or B I'm just
mentally preparing myself that I might
not have another gig right after but
it's you know I think it's like a
combination of the two really because I
kind of do want to take some time off
but I don't really actually see myself
slowing down anytime soon like for
instance today I said this is my last
project for a while I'm gonna take some
time off then I got sent a music video
offer literally during the day today and
I accepted it so I'm doing I'm doing a
music video after this so III I don't
think I actually am taking any time off
I think I'm just when you do have
downtime do you get nervous or restless
oh yeah yeah I mean I talked about that
in the other interview but I was like
you know you have to like for me I
always go oh yeah I want to I want to
take time off and do this stuff and then
you know like I'll go like two days
without working on something and I'll be
like what are you doing with your life
you're not doing anything you need to
like do something right something create
something because if I'm not like
working on something I start to realize
like wow I'm just kind of sitting at
home watching Netflix that's like I
should probably start
doing something because when your whole
life is working in this industry you
don't have a day job or like maybe you
do have a day job but for me I don't
have a day job so when I'm like not
working on a project I'm just sitting at
home spending money and I'm like wow my
bank account is starting to deplete
because I'm spending the money I made
and I'm not doing anything else but
spending money and watching Netflix I
know you're active on social media you
have over a hundred thousand plus
followers what's the feedback that you
get a lot from people on Twitter and
Instagram Facebook I mean I I seem to
get really good feedback you know I have
a lot of a lot of Twitter fans and
followers that like like what I do and
and also like Facebook as well
I kind of find it interesting because I
wanted to keep my Facebook really more
personal but I realize I I don't know
more than ninety percent of the people
on my Facebook now and Twitter I I don't
really know most of them either I mean
except like you know I do interact with
my fans and I respond to them and I see
I read every tweed and favor them and I
send them like you know an automatic DM
that says like hey check out my movies
and then they'll respond and I'll
respond back and a lot of people asked
me questions about making films and so
like I like to answer and be available
for that and you know I I love I love
having my Twitter my social media and I
actually believe it or not been able to
cast projects through social media like
you know one of my good friends Jonathan
Lipnicki I was a fan of his work I met
him through Twitter well I'm like I now
were really close friends and we've
worked together on two projects it's so
it's it's you know it's it's it's fun
and interesting in that in that respect
but you know I also find it interesting
as well on another flip side because my
auto DM goes out and goes hey you know
check out my movies on Amazon or
whatever and like I'll get responses
from all these people around the world
saying like hey I love your movies I saw
like you know this one or that one and
like all of them are always responding
saying oh I love a more I've seen him
and my my response is like either a like
a distributor owes me a lot of money
that I
don't know about or be or sorry is so
distracting uh either a a distributor
owes me a lot of money I don't know
about or B which is I think the more
likely one is you know things are
probably getting downloaded on the
internet a lot because I mean a perfect
a perfect instance of piracy is like you
know a movie I did I won't say which one
but the first like month it was out it
only like shipped like five thousand
units and then I looked at like one of
those like piracy websites and it had
something like a hundred and fifty
thousand downloads Wow and I was like
wow like if I only had like a dollar for
every single time that that happened
it'd be you know but at least they're
watching them right not advocating
piracy but do you think that it can ever
help someone's career or that it can
help a project in some way I think
sometimes like you look at that movie um
Inc if you saw that that movie was they
actually just released it for free
online they've encouraged the piracy of
it
so I think yes and no I mean personally
I'm I'm against piracy because I think
it's stealing legitimately stealing from
the filmmaker and you know I know it's
kind of weird to say but it's like yeah
it's messed up to pirate stuff but if
you're gonna pirate stuff at least don't
pirate the indie films you know like the
really low-budget indie stuff like you
know the difference between you know one
extra DVD and and one extra download is
like somebody's rent that month possibly
so it's like you know don't I so I it's
like I feel for people because I have
like a lot of friends that like hour at
this and haven't really been doing like
well with it because of because of
piracy so I I mean I want people to
understand that it really does hurt the
filmmaker it really does hmm you know
how do you think a lot of people in your
generation and in slightly older feel
because they've gotten so much for free
on the internet how do they view it I
mean the weird thing about it is like
you know I will be talking to like
friends like friends from high school or
like friends from you know from
childhood from like you know elementary
school or whatever people I've known for
years
years and I'll be like hey you should
check out my new movie blah blah blah
and they'll be like they'll be like oh
yeah sure I'll just like download it or
like oh yeah watch it on like you know
this website or whatever and I'll be
like you're literally just telling me
you're gonna steal for me like would you
really come up to me and be like oh yeah
I'm gonna take $20 out of your wallet
like no but for some reason it's so like
okay amongst that like they they
actually think that it's it's become so
part of the culture that like it's fine
when it's really not so I think if
there's like a way to find to like
monetize that like you know I think if
we release like movies for free online
with ads on them or something that's at
least better than then then having them
stolen but like you know you look at
like those websites that have the movies
hosted for free and all the all this
traffic's driven to web sites they're
making money on those sites because like
they are selling ad space on those sites
those people are making a lot of money
off of our hard work so you know what do
you think of YouTube having various ways
to watch either films or videos without
the ad but then you pay for a
subscription do you think that your
generation is okay with that because
they're so used to I definitely think
they are I mean look at like Netflix
like I actually like prefer I don't
watch TV shows on television anymore I
wait for the season to be on Netflix
because with my schedule like I'm not
able to like go like well once a week I
have an hour at this time to watch this
show I go like alright I have three days
off I'm gonna watch an entire season of
you know Law & Order or like I have
three days off I'm gonna watch every
episode of Jessica Jones which I did I
watched I watched every episode of
Breaking Bad in like four days like
every season because I was just like I
have time to do it and the funny thing
about that is I got like an email from
Netflix asking if I was okay I think
that's like because it played like
non-stop like and I guess like like I
didn't sleep for like 48 hours like they
legitimately thought like maybe I had
died and just left knit Netflix on but
there was like it goes like one of those
like are you still watching and I'm like
like yes stop making me feel bad about
this like it's a good show leave me
alone what do you think is the big
his threat to indie filmmaking currently
I mean I definitely say piracy and then
the other threat to indie filmmaking is
I mean jeez I pretty much just say like
piracy really like that and like and
then you know just like fans support
really just because like you know you I
I feel like what I notice is a lot of
people say they're very supportive of
indie films and you know it's it's like
one thing I noticed like a lot of people
and maybe this is just an LA thing but
people are like oh I love indie films
and I love you know I love like foreign
films and I love documentaries but like
if you actually like look at the
statistics of like the sales of indie
films documentaries and foreign films or
like the statistics of how many people
actually watch them on Netflix or
whatever they don't actually watch them
they just like to say that they watch
them so it's it's one of those things
like statistically speaking they get the
least amount of plays out of anything
else so it's I think I think the I think
it's if people like to sound like they
like something versus actually support
it like I'm the person who goes out to
see indie films in theaters you know and
and and that's like that's that's
important like if especially like for me
like I make John refills not not just
indie films but I I'm known for making
genre films like horror movies I support
any horror movie that comes out in
theaters
I will go see it in theaters whether I
think it's good whether I think it's bad
whether I think it's gonna be good
whether I think it's gonna be bad I go
see it in theaters because there will be
a time with the way the industry is
going if they don't get supported in
theaters they will stop coming out in
theatres
it will only be those major tentpole
movies so like the way I look at it is
like we have a responsibility to support
the things that we actually do care
about within the theater or else we will
have a time where we don't see these
things in theatres anymore what do you
think people say that they love foreign
films documentaries whatever is it
because they want to sound like a
cinephile or it's romantic it's what is
the reason I mean yeah I think so it's I
think it's the same thing like you know
like when people say
like classical music that that just died
do we need it or now what's the
definition of a cinephile
I guess the definition of a cinephile is
like a person who really truly loves
movies and supports them I mean like you
know I was a film collector like you
know I was I was the kid who like you
know growing up I watched every movie
that came out I would you know I would
look for the obscure films I would go to
the local video store and like rent
anything and I'd talk with the video
clerk and be like hey which what movie
can I get and like they'd recommend
stuff and I look for stuff and like
that's how I found out about old boy and
Ichi the Killer and all that stuff from
like you know the local people of the
video stores and like I would go one of
my favorite pastimes is I would go to
like you know like blockbuster 2020
video and like rummaged through for like
hours through like the five 420 bins and
like buy as many movies as I possibly
could I have a DVD collection of 6,000
movies and like you know I had made some
good money like doing like like
promotions for for first you know events
and stuff before I got into movies when
I was like younger I did that and I also
liked worked in a restaurant and I took
all the money that I had saved up which
was like a couple grand and instead of
going to film school you know I I was
gonna make my pure joy and stuff but I
spent all that money and bought as many
obscure movies on Amazon as I possibly
could and was just watching like tons
and tons of obscure movies like stuff
that was like a hundred dollars for a
DVD because it was completely out of
print I would hunt for like the really
expensive stuff that like nobody else
had cuz I was like I need to see this
and I think sadly like that that because
of the the death of the video stores I
feel like that's that's like dying away
like you know people wanting to hunt
down these obscure things and like the
collectors and stuff I mean like and I'm
guilty of it too because like I own
6,000 DVDs and I haven't bought a DVD in
two years because I now go well I have
it all on Netflix and like I justify it
in my head even though I know hey I
should buy a DVD right now like I go see
him in theaters
like rent the movie on like you know
Amazon Prime or whatever but like for
some reason I just like I've now somehow
in my head
convinced myself oh well you know it'll
be on Netflix that's that's a Netflix
movie that's one that I'll wait for
Netflix I don't need that you know and I
find it I find it interesting that like
you know that's you know we've become so
complacent with in our society that
we're able to just right off wanting to
own something and wanting to collect it
and so you know I think like true
cinephiles are dying away because like I
even though I love film and I'm I'm a
student of film till the day I die
I definitely have started to feel like
I'm no longer a truce in a file because
I don't go out and search for those
things anymore the things that brought
me into loving this it's like you know
we don't have that that that video store
that's sanctuary to go in and get those
things anymore and I think it's I think
it's sad I think it's a sad a sad thing
and you know it's uh I I definitely feel
like you know I'm 23 years old and when
I have when I have kids I I definitely
feel like it's gonna be sad that they'll
never be able to go to like a video
store to look through a bunch of DVDs
and stuff